star wars episode 8 has officially
started filming so if you live anywhere
near an aircraft hangar a cool forest or
a giant laser moon keep an eye out for
poe dameron and company I'm Kate and
this is your gamespot news update Disney
chief executive Bob Iger has revealed
that directory and Johnson has now begun
production on the next part of the
blockbuster sci-fi saga speaking to
Entertainment Weekly Iger also stressed
the importance of keeping standards high
for future movies in the series there is
no better way to propel this franchise
into the future than producing quality
products he said filming of Star Wars
Episode eight the next chapter of the
legendary saga has just commenced and it
will be in theaters December 2017 and
production of Episode nine and twenty
nineteen release has also begun last
month it was announced that the release
date of episode 8 had moved back from a
20-17 to December that year as with the
force awakens principal photography is
to take place in London I got also
provided an update on the status of
rogue one the first of the standalone
Star Wars movies which is due in
december this year filming of rogue one
is virtually completed and we absolutely
love what we've seen so far he said this
is the first of a set of plans
standalone stories and we're already in
pre-production on our next one for
release in May of 2018 got any theories
on what we'll see in episode 8 let me
know in the comments or come if I me on
Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it games but
you